le soir de l'élection 2011 qu'un des
deux principaux candidats le républicain
george w bush et le démocrate et ex vice
président al gore n'est proclamé
vainqueur
la confusion règne sur les plateaux de
télévision
vers 20 heures les réseaux déclare
d'abord al gore vainqueur puis à 22h
bourgeois il prévoit une avance
insurmontable pour george w.bush en
floride
al gore appelle son adversaire pour lui
concéder la victoire mais à trois heures
du matin les résultats se resserre al
gore se rétracter déclare que c'est lui
qui a gagné
il faudra attendre plus d'un mois pour
connaître le résultat final car l'iar
comptage en floride l'écart est trop
mince
la loi exige dans quatre comtés au
maximum à gordes mandat recomptage
manuel à miami et pang beach
c'est là que tout dérape des bulletins
de vote sur fish perforé sont annulées
parce que le trou est mal percer ce sont
du fameux tchad
dans par le beach les bulletins dit
papillon défavorise trop le candidat
démocrate des blier d'électeurs ont été
radiés parreira à l'issue de recomptage
bush demeure en avance et al gore en
demande un autre qui ne changera rien
c'est là que tout se joue
le 12 décembre la cour suprême décrète
que le recomptage en cours est
inconstitutionnelle et qu'il est
impossible d'effectuer un recomptage
dans les délais prescrits par la
constitution
ça a été terminé 5 à 4 en encore de
george w bush pour arrêter le recomptage
mais on a eu cinq de cinq juges
finalement qu'il est dénommé part des
républicains qui ont voté pour allaiter
leur comptage des cinq juges qui étaient
considérés comme les plus conservateurs
de la cour suprême alors l'histoire
peut-elle se répéter peut être même avec
une certaine ironie et l'on est dans une
situation aussi à la nomination récente
de la juger et nikon hibarette où les
juges conservateurs ont une super
majorité à la course sprint six voix
contre trois et trois de ses juges
antinomie à reprise dans tron ont été
jugées encore seul mètre carré n'a été
ni conte et mareth finale corps de mener
les juges car à noter qu'au départ il
faisait partie avec le juge en chef john
roberts de l'équipe les gars de duke ans
de george bush en 2000 la cour suprême
des etats-unis confirment ainsi la
victoire de george w.bush en floride par
537 voix
des cubains diront que ce sont les voix
de compatriotes furieux du renvoi forcé
vers cuba du jeune naufragés de la mer
elian gonzalez par l'administration
démocrate de bill clinton quelques mois
plus tôt avec la floride george w.bush
obtient 271 voix du collège électoral
il lui en fallait deux cent soixante dix
jean michel leprince sera du canada
montréal